our first speeder speaker this morning
is Adam
Angie upski he's the CEO and founder of
open the books calm the world's largest
private database of US public sector
spending whether at the federal state or
local level what this means is his
database is pretty huge I think and
getting bigger does it doesn't include
Hillsdale by the way since we don't take
a dime of federal taxpayer money thank
you his organization's oversight model
has led to some impressive results
including grand jury's indictments
congressional hearings and legislation
he speaks frequently around the country
on the topic of big data journalism and
forensic auditing techniques and I think
he'll explain that in greater detail
previously he co-founded the publishing
company home pages directories he's a
senior policy contributor at Forbes and
his work has been featured in a variety
of national publications he makes
frequent appearances on radio and
television he's the author of the
encounter broadside titled operation
drain the swamp so in order in order to
in order to drain the swamp it helps to
know how deep the swamp is exactly and
that's his topic today the depth of the
swamp please welcome to the podium Adam
and Jeff's key
Tim Kasper thank you very much for that
kind introduction president Larry Arne
director Matt bell supporters of
Hillsdale College thank you thank you
for this opportunity to share our
mission and vision in 2017 published on
the editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal and aired on the Fox News
Channel
our organization at open the books comm
launched our oversight report of the Ivy
League colleges and I know of no better
example of the depth of the swamp the
true size scope and power of the federal
government here's what we found over the
six years of our report the eight
schools of the Ivy League collected
forty two billion dollars of US taxpayer
subsidies special tax breaks and direct
federal payments on contracts and grants
we compared the Ivy League's federal
contracting business on the direct
receipt of federal contracts in grants
at twenty five billion dollars versus
their educational mission they only
collected twenty two billion dollars
worth of undergraduate student tuition
in the six year period they are more
federal contractor today than they are
educator and we found a lot of taxpayer
abuse in their federal grants two
examples Cornell University they took a
million dollars on a study where it
hurts the most to be stung by a bee
Columbia University they took 5.6
million dollars to create fake
voicemails from the Year 2065 describing
the world after it's been decimated by
climate change the Ivy's can't make the
argument that they need taxpayer
subsidies they have a collective
endowment of a hundred and twenty
billion dollars so here's our conclusion
there is no public purpose for
working-class taxpayers for middle-class
taxpayers for any of us to subsidize the
wealthy Ivy League
so let's compare the Ivy League at 25
billion dollars in a receipt of federal
grants and contracts over this 6-year
period versus Hillsdale College over the
same six year period we fact-checked the
Hillsdale promise of no federal money
and guess what it's true they're not in
the federal checkbook zero dollars and
today that's what we call an American
miracle and it's it's only possible
because of your support of this college
thank you for supporting Hillsdale
College as many of you know I'm from
Illinois and it is the Superbowl of
corruption in Illinois our number one
manufactured product is corruption and
our governors are famous you know one
point we had four out of the last nine
governors that had been convicted and it
served time in the federal penitentiary
in 2013 we actually had two governor's
in federal prison at the same time one
from each party it was Republican George
Ryan and Democrat Rod Blagojevich and I
remember when rahm emanuel promised to
clean up the city of chicago in 2011
rahm emanuel ran for mayor of this city
on two promises to end pay to play to
end the historic culture of corruption
in city hall pay-to-play is when you
give campaign cash and expect to receive
a government contract and sure enough
after a manual one for mayor he issued
an executive order prohibiting city
contractors from giving him campaign
cash in 2015 the Emmy award-winning
journalist John Stossel called me from
Fox News headquarters in New York City
Rahm was running for reelection and
Stossel asked me if we could fact check
the mayor's promises and I said yes we
can and here is what we found
we took the city of Chicago checkbook we
mashed it up with Rahm Emmanuel's
campaign donor disclosures
six-hundred city contractors gave Rahm
Emanuel seven million dollars of
campaign cash and those contractors had
reaped two billion dollars in city
payments in god we trust'
Illinois politicians we must audit I am
hopeful and optimistic about our future
despite the corruption in Illinois and
across the country because you and I we
have been given the greatest gift in the
last 5,000 years of human history we've
been given a constitution that
recognizes our inalienable rights our
rights come from God and not government
and we instituted a government to secure
our rights and our founders knew that we
needed the tools to hold that government
accountable our founders knew that
knowledge is power and they recognize
the power of transparency and they wrote
it into our founding documents and it's
article 1 section 9 of the US
Constitution and it states that a
regular statement and account of the
receipts and expenditures of all public
money shall be published from time to
time today there's a simple
interpretation post every dime online in
real time open the books
my name is Adam Angie FC and I found it
open the books calm on a simple vision
to capture and post online every dime
taxed and spent at every level of
government across the entire country
that's at the federal level the state
level and the local level our vision is
to empower regular people where they
live with the information to hold the
political class accountable for tax and
spend decisions and our honorary
chairman is the former legendary US
senator from Oklahoma dr. Tom Coburn in
2013 Coburn made the time 100 most
influential persons in the world list
and we are privileged to be locked arm
and arm
fighting these battles in the same
trench with dr. Tom Coburn
we've had a lot of success capturing
data we are the world's largest private
database of public sector expenditures
and here's what our database is
comprised of at the federal level since
the year 2001 all disclosed federal
spending at the state level 49 out of 50
state checkbook spending most going back
10 or a dozen years at the local level
in 50,000 of the most substantial public
bodies in the country for the first time
in US history we've compiled virtually
every single public employee salary
record at every level of government last
year we compiled records from 23 million
public employees salary and pension
records when candidate Donald Trump won
for president here's what we found at
the federal level we did an oversight
report called mapping the swamp a study
of the administrative state and we found
that the federal bureaucracy is very
expensive it's 1 million dollars a
minute it's a half billion dollars a day
we found a new minimum wage in 78 of the
largest federal agencies and the minimum
wage the average pay is a hundred
thousand dollars today for a federal
bureaucrat
but it's not even about the salary
get performance bonuses our auditors
found that the agencies gave out 1
million performance bonuses to
bureaucrats costing taxpayers 1.1
billion dollars and that shacks most
people they don't know how a million
federal bureaucrats can qualify for a
performance bonus most people don't
think government's running that well so
we dug deeper and we found that ninety
nine point six percent of the federal
bureaucrats are rated fully successful
and that's actually impossible the
advertised purity of Ivory soap is only
ninety nine point four percent they're
highly compensated on salary they get
performance bonuses and they also get
paid time off if you hit your three-year
anniversary as a federal bureaucrat you
get incredibly forty-three days of paid
time off that's eight and a half weeks
we estimate that small benefit cost the
American taxpayers twenty billion
dollars a year because if you're giving
eight and a half weeks of paid time off
your payroll head counts have to
increase little pull the room
we got about eight hundred people here
today who receives eight and a half
weeks of paid time off forty-three days
we got one guy that said in the entire
room
this isn't France we also have
transparency problems because the
Federal Bureau bureaucracy gets pensions
except you and I we help fund those
pensions we guarantee those pensions and
you and I don't get to see those
pensions you see under existing federal
Freedom of Information Act law when you
when a bureaucrat retires or your member
of Congress their retirement payout is
considered private information and we we
need to change that law
those performance bonuses we know
there's a million of them but I can't
tell you who received them the
transparency was negotiated away the
performance bonuses are shielded from
disclosure because of the union
contracts so we have a lot of work to do
on paying pensions here's another
transparency problem you know we mapped
the swamp that the president inherited
from the Obama administration and we
were upset because there was 3,500 names
and salaries redacted from the
responsive record and then in 2017 we
filed our request we got the information
and two hundred and fifty five thousand
names and salaries were redacted and we
estimated twenty billion dollars was
hidden in the swamp the swamp was
fighting back this year just about a
month ago we got the 2018 federal
executive payroll through the door and
three hundred and fifty thousand names
were redacted we estimate we don't know
who received 30 billion dollars worth of
federal payroll you and I we have a lot
of work to do to simply open the books
and hold the administrate accountable
but consider this the federal swamp is
dwarfed by the state and local swamps it
open the books calm I can tell you that
there are two million public employees
across the entire country at the federal
state and local level who are highly
compensated in our definition of that is
that they make six figures one hundred
thousand dollars a year there's two
million of them four hundred thousand
are at the federal level and 1.6 million
of them are in our own backyards at the
state and local level right here in
Florida in the small town of Dana Beach
the city attorney for two years made
over four hundred thousand dollars out
earning every president ever in Chicago
the tree trimmers lop off six figures up
to a hundred and five thousand dollars
in LA County in Los Angeles the
lifeguards they get free sunscreen
allowance
and they can earn up to three hundred
and sixty-five thousand dollars as
lifeguards in New York City in the New
York City Public Schools the school
district janitors out earn the
principals because of the union contract
the janitors are making up to two
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
and I need the tools to be able to hold
our elected officials accountable
locally for tax-and-spend decisions and
it opened the books calm we are giving
you free tools to do that all 23 million
public employee salaries are in a free
mobile app for Apple and Android called
open the books it takes the entire
payroll file of the country localizes it
to your zip code so you can see who by
name for what unit of government makes
how much money we can't complain about
Washington DC unless we have good
government where we live and we need to
fact start fact-checking our local
politicians on their promises our team
noticed that in San Francisco there was
a new candidate running for mayor London
breed and she was promising to literally
clean up the streets of San Francisco
you see in San Francisco there are 8,000
homeless people and it's a crisis and
many of those people are defecating on
city streets she promised to clean up
the streets so after she was in office
for a year our team decided to
fact-check her programs to see how she
was doing and here's what we found we
literally mapped on our interactive
mapping platform the San Francisco human
waste challenge and yes on that map we
did use brown pins
let me tell you there is a brown out in
the Bay Area the whole city was brown it
trended on national Twitter was
international news we took nine years of
case reports of human waste in the
public way we put it on our map and in
2011 there was 5,000 cases in 2015 there
was 13,000 cases in 2017 there was
21,000 cases then 28,000 in last year in
2019
there was 31,000 cases of human waste in
the public way we mapped a hundred and
forty thousand cases over a nine year
period and that is a human health
catastrophe I don't have to tell you
that California has a lot of problems
every year our auditors file state
checkbook requests that's for the line
by law and state expenditures in all 50
states and were able to collect 49 out
of 50 states only California has
rejected our request California
Controller Betty Yee rejected our
request this year
oddly saying that she couldn't locate
her words any of the 49 million
individual bills she paid last year she
spent over three hundred billion dollars
and a hundred billion of that came back
from Washington DC that's our money in
the Golden State we deserve to be able
to follow the money and so we sued Betty
E this year to begin the process of
forcing open the California state
checkbook expenditures
and this is not our first rodeo in 2013
we sued Republican comptroller in
Illinois
Judy part of inca to Pincus said that
the state doesn't have a magical
checkbook and we reminded two Pinker
that the state doesn't have magical
taxpayers either so he sued her and
within nine months we'd opened up seven
years worth of line-by-line payments in
the state of Illinois in 2018 we sued
Republican State Auditor Cynthia cloud
in Wyoming what cloud said it would take
years and years to produce a state
checkbook so we sued her and within ten
months we had six years worth of
line-by-line expenses we have never lost
a state checkbook transparency fight and
we expect to win in the state of
California as well
when we opened the books in California
what do you think we'll find well here's
the first project that we're going to do
we're gonna take governor Gavin Newsom
Champaign donor disclosures we're gonna
mash it up with the state checkbook
vendor list and we're gonna see if
governor Newsom is soliciting campaign
cash from state vendors because that
would be highly unethical we did this in
Oregon governor Kate brown solicited 557
state vendors for 2.6 million dollars in
campaign cash and those vendors had
reaped 4.6 billion dollars in state
payments we're gonna break news right
now in March we're coming out with the
same report and Governor Andrew Cuomo
and the state of New York here's our
preliminary findings preliminary
findings show that three hundred thirty
seven state vendors were solicited for
4.6 million dollars worth of campaign
cash and those vendors had received six
point three billion dollars worth of New
York State payments the elites in this
country have gained the system for their
political power and their personal
benefit and you know this this is a
message that resonates across the entire
political spectrum the disruptors in
2016 for president you had Bernie
Sanders on the left and Donald Trump on
the right and they ran on eerily similar
campaign messages that the system is
rigged and it's rigged for insiders and
it opened the books calm we we show you
by shining a white-hot spotlight just
how bad it is you tell me what
government program is running well could
it be farm subsidies in urban areas
where there are no farms
we did an oversight report of the
federal farm subsidies flowing into New
York City Washington DC and Chicago and
my favorite story comes out of Chicago I
guess the corruption stories are always
better in Illinois the Reverend Minister
Louis Farrakhan the founder of the
Nation of Islam is a farmer in a
seventeen year period to his home in
Hyde Park three hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars worth of farm subsidies
were mailed what government program is
running well let's take a look at an
obscure federal agency called the Small
Business Administration
you know the SBA they're supposed to be
funding mom-and-pop businesses on Main
Street those men and women that have
good ideas but can't find financing in
the private marketplace so we did an
oversight report on them last summer and
in a five-year period we found a hundred
and ten million dollars flowing into zip
code nine oh two one oh and that's
Beverly Hills California
it was 1.75 million dollars worth of
low-cost taxpayer backed financing that
flowed to their french wine importer 2.1
million dollars floated diva limousine
and they shuttle the stars and starlets
in hollywood and 2.2 million dollars
flowed into their eyeglass designers
whose frames are worn by Brad Pitt and
Tom Cruise and four million dollars
worth of cheap financing backed by
taxpayers went to the Beverly Hills
exclusive diamond broker since 2007 our
team has quantified 300 million dollars
flowed to America's private Country
clubs golf clubs swim clubs beach clubs
tennis clubs and yacht clubs across the
country we found that in a five-year
period fourteen billion dollars didn't
go to Main Street it went to Wall Street
with no transparency after that now in
America we must never demonize success
but you and I we shouldn't subsidize it
either
so you tell me what government program
is running well could it be healthcare
well the right the rising cost of health
care is crushing the American dream you
know last year the average family across
the country paid twenty thousand dollars
on health insurance premiums deductibles
and out-of-pocket costs and so we did an
oversight report of 82 largest nonprofit
public Charity Hospital groups across
the country and we found that these
nonprofit hospitals these public
charities are making huge profits these
nonprofits in one year the latest year
available our auditors found they admit
to 40 billion dollars worth of net asset
increase in one year it was a 23 percent
year-over-year increase in their net
assets that they admit on their iris
disclosure forms and that's the
definition of gaming the system
pocketing forty billion dollars as a
nonprofit in one year without paying a
dime z' worth of federal income tax and
it gets a little worse the pay to their
ceos went up to fifty nine point 1
million dollars over a four year period
ascension healthcare in st. Louis it was
fifty nine million dollars to their CEO
Kaiser Permanente in Oakland California
it was twenty nine point eight million
dollars over a four year period it was
banner health care in Phoenix Arizona 27
million dollars in Illinois advocate
health care 27 million dollars went to
their CEO over a four-year period and
joined me public charities are supposed
to be about public service and if you're
going to be an executive at a public
charity non for profit you shouldn't
have a compensation package that rivals
Wall Street investment bankers so what
government program is
well could it be Veterans Affairs so you
remember in 2014 the scandal at Veterans
Affairs were up to one thousand six dad
while waiting to see a doctor because
there weren't enough doctors and they
were placed on waiting lists and the
scandal broke at the Phoenix facility
the VA facility in Phoenix Arizona were
up to 40 veterans died while waiting to
see a doctor and we took a look at the
payroll numbers at that time and there
was 30 100 employees in Phoenix at the
VA but only 226 doctors so Congress
through billions of dollars at the VA
and since 2015 we've fact-checked
what the VA has done with the money
they've actually added to the payroll
headcount 36,000 positions but less than
3,000 of those positions are doctors and
the average veteran today still waits 70
days to see a doctor because there
aren't enough doctors and this can't be
the end of the story our veterans they
deserve basic health care they fought
for us and we we need to fight for them
during the scandal in 2014 our team had
opened the books calmly forensic audit
of the VA checkbook and this is what we
found coded as furniture was twenty
million dollars worth of high-end luxury
artwork
it was Christmas trees priced like cars
27-foot Christmas trees costing $21,000
it was sculptures priced like five
bedroom homes at a Palo Alto VA facility
in California that treats blind veterans
we found they purchased two fancy
sculptures for $700,000 and our findings
rocketed to Good Morning America and ABC
News and they were picked up by Chuck
Grassley who wrote an oversight letter
to the VA then Secretary Robert McDonald
and within 34 days after national airing
on national news the VA secretary
apologized for the purchases and
instituted new rules to stop the
practice of purchasing high-end luxury
art on a go-forward basis and that's the
power of transparency
you can't make America great again
unless you make America accountable
again twenty-three point two trillion
dollars worth of national debt shocking
every day we had four billion dollars to
the national debt year over year this
year we're gonna rack up a trillion
dollar national debt that's shocking
President Donald Trump has signed three
budget bills adding four point six
trillion dollars to our national debt
and I get it the appropriations bills
come out of Congress they come out of
the house and far too often patronage
Republicans in Congress have joined
Democrats to drain the US Treasury from
the left and so our team had opened the
books calm we investigated Congress and
last fall on that Tucker Carlson show on
Fox News we launched our findings our
report was called the congressional
favor Factory we took a look at four
powerful Republican congressman and four
powerful members of Congress on the
Democratic side here's just one example
at a Nashville Tennessee
Democratic congressman Jim Cooper he's a
powerful member of Congress he sits on
US House Oversight and Government Reform
and he's a member of the Budget
Committee where they carve up the budget
his number one campaign contributor is
based in his district and it's the
executives Chancellor key employees and
key executives at Vanderbilt University
those people have given him over a
hundred and thirty five thousand dollars
with the campaign cash helping him get
reelected
they've also employed him for 12 years
he was an adjunct professor and made
total compensation of two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and Vanderbilt
University just in the last five years
has reaped two point three billion
dollars worth of federal payments so
here's what we found we found that is
completely legal today
to be a large federal contractor based
in a congressman's district helping him
get reelected employing him and reaping
billions of dollars out of the federal
treasury Congress needs to crackdown on
the ethics laws these conflicts of
interest must end
and it's an election season and the
president has tipped his reelection
messaging quote America will never be a
socialist country and he'll have a lot
more credibility on the issue if he's
not seen as draining the Treasury from
the right here's how the president can
lead on spending our organization mapped
a spending plan for the president six
times in The Wall Street Journal and USA
Today we published an open letter to
President Donald Trump that was the
first page the second page was a hundred
outrageous examples of federal taxpayer
abuse so today we'll go through three of
those examples and our four point
strategy for the president we encourage
the president to embrace the
transparency revolution declare war on
waste and as commander-in-chief defend
the American taxpayer against waste
fraud corruption and taxpayer abuse
first prong open an audit all spending
second prong cut 5% it's a modest goal
and then keep going I mean for crying
out loud in 1982 the grace Commission
under President Reagan identified one
out of every three dollars was waste and
it's probably worked worse today prong
three mobilize the federal work force
they know where the bodies are buried
prong four the president's really good
at this one communicate with the
American people keep us updated on the
progress of the transparency revolution
use Twitter
[Laughter]
the president will find it's a
target-rich environment to cut waste
here's the first big area where he can
go federal grant-making last year
incredibly 700 billion dollars went out
the door on subsidies grants and
giveaways our team did an oversight
report called where's the pork here are
just some of our findings $200,000
created a new mobile app to help Chinese
children cross their busy streets
700,000 dollars went to a Senior Center
outside Boston Massachusetts to teach
the seniors Tai Chi Nassau funded a 1.1
million dollar outreach to prepare the
nation's religions for the discovery of
extraterrestrial life one point four
million dollars funded sex education for
California prostitutes who could have
probably taught the class 20 million
dollars went to the airport on Martha's
Vineyard the playground for the East
Coast money elites and the Hollywood
superstars they can pay their own way
we need a transparency revolution we
need a war on waste here's the second
vertical that the president can
concentrate on improper and mistake in
payments here's the definition of an
improper payment a payment to the wrong
person or in the wrong amount or under
the wrong set of federal rules or all of
the above let's just start with the 1
billion dollars paid to dead people last
year people that had a death certificate
on file with the federal agencies the
agencies admit to continuing to pay them
nearly 1 billion dollars the Social
Security Administration admits that last
year alone they overpaid 10 billion
dollars and so we dug a little deeper on
that number Social Security also admits
that they have 6 million active Social
Security numbers of people aged 112 and
over there's only 40 people aged 112 and
over in the entire world Medicare and
Medicaid admit last year they paid sixty
seven billion dollars in overpayments in
Democratic presidential candidate Bernie
Sanders wants Medicare for all he wants
to put that program on steroids
really the IRS Internal Revenue Service
don't try this at home but the IRS
admits they overpaid one out of every
four dollars on the federal income tax
program on the Earned Income Tax Credit
to the tune of eighteen point four
billion dollars last year we need a war
on waste we need a transparency
revolution and we need to challenge and
change the culture of corruption in
Washington DC
here's the third spending vertical the
president can concentrate on and that's
the year-end use it or lose it
spending phenomenon the federal the
federal fiscal year ends in September it
is Christmas in September for federal
contractors our organization that an
oversight report of the 67 federal
agencies that we found spent a hundred
billion dollars in the last month of the
fiscal year spending down their budgets
this year so that I get the same or more
money from Congress next year and here's
some of the ways they spent down their
budgets we found we found 300 million
dollars spent down the vehicle budget
purchasing cars trucks snowmobiles motor
scooters and and other vehicles we found
four hundred and sixty million dollars
spent by the agencies on redecorating
and on furniture we found five hundred
million dollars a half billion dollars
spent by the agencies on PR that's
public relations spending down their
marketing promotion and advertising
budgets and I can tell you nothing
rankles taxpayers more than spending
taxpayer money to convince taxpayers to
spend even more taxpayer money on a
larger size and scope of government the
Pentagon the Department of Defense spent
sixty two billion dollars in the last
month of the fiscal year it was one out
of every four or five dollars that they
spent on contracting on the year they
spent in the last month of the year we
found they spent nine thousand three
hundred dollars on a club leather chair
they spent a million dollars on PBR the
Professional Bull Riders Association the
Pentagon spent down there lobster tail
and snow crab budget spending four point
six million dollars in the last month on
lobster tail and snow crab and so we dug
a little deeper and when we reached out
for comment the Pentagon admitted to
spending twenty five million dollars on
lobster tail and snow crab over an 18
period we also published at The Wall
Street Journal
an annual figure of what the pentagon's
was spending on expensive coffee cups up
to 1218 dollars on these expensive
coffee cups and Senator Chuck Grassley
picked that up wrote an oversight letter
to the Department of Defense he got the
program stopped but they admitted they
had spent three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars on that program of
expensive coffee cups and I'd feel a lot
better about all of this spending at the
Department of Defense if they could pass
their audit the president the the audit
of the Pentagon has been on the books
for decades but nobody enforced it well
President Trump didn't force it he
mandated it the Pentagon spent a year
there was 1,200 auditors they spent four
hundred million dollars on the audit and
the Pentagon flunked it
we need a transparency revolution we
need to challenge the culture of
corruption in Washington DC I just want
to close with the with the following
story and it is good news I received a
call two weeks ago from the White House
from the executive office the president
the Office of Management and Budget and
they said that for the first time in our
nation's history included in the
President's budget to Congress is a
chapter on the elimination of wasteful
spending and they said that our work our
oversight work at open the books com had
helped inspire that chapter
they sent me a copy of it and the
president recognized in that chapter the
following and this is really important
quote that a bloated duplicate 'iv and
wasteful federal government is a threat
to America's future and that's really
good news
we called for a transparency revolution
and in the president's budget to
Congress he commits to oversight
resources on every single federal
spending program we called for a war on
waste and the president is declaring war
on waste we called for five percent cuts
in the agencies and the President's
budget adopted that cut we called for
the elimination of improper payments and
the president is committed to it we
called for the end of use it or lose it
urines spending the president cited in
his budget our organization by name
bullet-pointed our findings and
hyperlinked and footnote at our
oversight report on our website we
believe that transparency is
revolutionising United States public
policy and politics join us join the
transparency revolution
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
well I'm glad you're clapping and that
you're not depressed if you feel
depressed fight the urge we're Americans
and we have a fighting spirit and this
is our moment thank you we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you
first of all great work fling down is
where all the secrets are and you've
done a heck of a job drilling down my
question to you is president trump
signed an order freezing hiring and
non-essential services when he first
came into office is that still into
effect and you know how many spots he's
eliminated so I don't know if that
specific executive order is still in
effect my thinking is that it probably
is but let's go to some of the research
that we've done that we feel is a
leading indicator by the president on
spending and that's a tranche of
spending he fully controls as the
executive and that's the White House
payroll and I'm a senior contributor at
Forbes the last three years I've written
about the White House payroll it's such
good news that were about the only ones
now writing about the White House
payroll President Trump has saved
taxpayers 20 million dollars on a leaner
White House payroll versus the same
years under the Obama administration we
found no evidence of czars the payroll
of the first lady is half 12 versus 24
under the previous first lady so the
president is leading by example his
payroll headcount in his first year he
was down 100 employees
he has slowly added employees back but
he's still down about 40 employees
versus the same period underneath the
Brock Obama administration and quite
evidently there's been a lot of winning
the president is doing more with less
I think you just gave an extraordinary
speech but I think it would be much more
effective if people like us could find
it online and share it with people we
know would that be possible yes we'll
post a transcript of it thank you very
much thank you I appreciate that very
much
I tell you our team you know we never
take any of this for granted my personal
story is I'm an entrepreneur so in 1997
my brother and I we started a publishing
company from scratch from our
apartment's and you know success in
America it's always impossible
and this is the genius of capitalism
because it squeezes you and brings out
your best for six years every one of our
employees out earn my brother and I my
brother had gone to Harvard Law School
didn't want to be a lawyer he wanted to
be an entrepreneur in up through year 5
we'd make a little bit he'd call me with
a capital call you know what that is
that's money that goes back into into
the business to grow the business in
year six we were a five million dollar
business but by year ten we were a
twenty million dollar business and we
were an overnight success and that's how
it works in America right but that's why
I fight so hard because if we're gonna
be taxed and if they're gonna spend it
we deserve to see it be able to follow
it and hold them accountable for honest
clean and effective spending
I did not see any papers being put on
your podium did you do all these out of
memory so I just turned 50 years old and
my eyes are starting to go I have seven
pages up here but I can't read them I'm
not gonna get a rod Blagojevich question
the president didn't call me if he did I
would have said mr. president you know
bad idea look in Illinois many of us are
here from Illinois and we live the heavy
boot of a corrupt government at all
levels and finally they never catch
anyone they never prosecute public
corruption they only prosecute people in
the private sector for crimes not in the
public sector for crimes they finally
caught this guy and now we're letting
him go early I just thought it was a bad
idea
I'd like to know if there's any avenue
for average Americans to report abuse
and waste that we see I'm a physician I
see Medicare abuse and waste I've tried
to report it and nothing ever happens I
know the VA that probably has issues not
only did they have too few physicians
but they don't work very hard why so I
think you just articulated why the
founders of our country feared
government and that's because the
accountability mechanism oftentimes is
shattered it's not even broken it's just
shattered and the president has
specifically at the VA worked with
Congress on a bipartisan basis to try to
reform the civil service laws to be able
to fire bad employees and more a lot
more needs to be done I was just on a
conference call with the House
Republican Study Committee and they are
they have
tens and tens of recommendations on how
to reform the federal bureaucracy and so
we do need operation drain the swamp the
president does need to focus on the
federal bureaucracy and I think he's got
a lot of insensitive a lot of incentive
to do so question to the speaker's right
thank you for your presentation I don't
know if you can collect this type of
data but I have a number of friends who
are highly compensated employees in the
federal government and they tell me that
it's very common to have other highly
compensated employees who are also on
total disability from other branches of
government and I've always wondered how
can you be totally disabled but be a
highly compensated employee in a
different department do you know
anything about that situation well yes
and please reach out to me I'd like some
more detail on that I want to give one
example it's a very high-level example
if you're from Illinois you probably
remember this example this Chicago
Tribune unearthed this example and it's
with former disgraced and convicted
congressman Jesse Jackson jr. so before
Jesse Jackson jr. was indicted he
claimed that Congress made him mentally
ill and we know that's true that's true
for the whole body but he gets he
qualified for fellow for dis federal
disability benefits and Social Security
benefits and I think this was 2012 and I
think his total benefit between the two
programs one of the programs is tax free
but he's getting a total benefit of
about 120 to 130 thousand dollars a year
in the thinking as he's still getting it
so he's collected nearly 1 million
dollars over this period of federal
disability benefits because Congress
made him mentally ill there needs to be
reforms in these areas and I'm highly
interested in these stories
just wondered if you could comment it's
always driven me crazy that the federal
budget automatically goes up every
single year every department gets eight
or ten percent more or whatever it is
number one is that a law written
somewhere can me president by executive
order eliminate that I mean I've never
heard of any company that ran anything
that their budget automatically
increased every single year even Reagan
although he tried never really cut
anything he cut out that increase that's
every year in the budget I just wonder
if you could enlighten us so look the
president's taking a lot of heat you
know we're running trillion-dollar
budget deficits the President's budget
delivers a path to balance the budget
over 15 years but the headline was
president cuts four point six trillion
dollars in federal spending including
food stamps and housing assistance and
most of the cuts are off that baseline
increase so the best example of exposing
this phenomenon comes from Rand Paul
last fall in the United States Senate
because he took it to the floor insisted
on a individual vote in a Republican
held US Senate on his bill called the
penny bill it would cut one cent of
actual spending year over a year and it
failed because Republican US senators
voted against it we have time for one
more question
thank you very much putting numbers to
this problem helps us all many many
years ago old late 60s I was a young
army
and then we were doing some budget work
in Washington DC found out that each
army headquarters had a different
accounting system
I suspect it's never got changed so
there's no way that the Department of
Defense would know exactly what was
going on because they couldn't compare
one army to the one army first army to
the Third Army the other comment I have
is I think one of the biggest problems
we have is in Congress because as soon
as you get a new Congress person in
there the first thing they do is they
sign them to a subcommittee and that
subcommittee usually has some kind of a
budget requirement and apparently their
their main project is to protect their
own budget so I wondered if you could
comment whether we can change or modify
Congress in any way to eliminate because
Congress is the one that writes the
budget and they're the ones that are
willing to apparently shut down the
government to prevent changes so our
role in this on Congress said open the
books calm is one of China net white-hot
spotlight and I'm prepared to say to you
today that Congress in 2019 was the
number one most wasteful federal
expenditure they spent 1.3 billion
dollars running Congress and all their
subcommittees and everything else but
they were only in session in the house
was only in session for 850 hours on the
year they didn't they're lazy on the
budget bills think about this speaker
Pelosi dropped a 20 318 page spending
bill spending 1.4 trillion dollars they
dropped the bill a couple of days ahead
of Christmas 24 hours before they voted
on it and it was written by lobbyists
that contained all kinds of pork and
taxpayer giveaways nobody even knew what
was in it there was no time to read it
when they passed it the Senate passed it
sent it to the president he's under
impeachment it's a couple of days before
Christmas he felt boxed in so he signed
it and look it's not representative
government in Congress if you don't know
what you're voting on
so these things we need to raise our
voice we need to call our member of
Congress and we need to ask them how
we're specifically are you defending the
United States taxpayer against waste
fraud corruption and abuse
thank you thank you very much this was
great I really enjoyed it thank you
[Applause]